hello everyone this game comes as a
suggestion from gordon mark teach and he
really does have a good taste in chess
games i will put a link to his leeches
account in the description below so you
can check it out and challenge him for a
game or two and this game it's it's one
of the coolest games i've ever seen it
was played in 2009 between American
chess prodigy Ray Robson he was 13 years
old at the time and the danish
grandmaster allen's dick rasmusson and
Robson wasn't a grandmaster at the time
this game was played he got his
Grandmaster title in 2010 so one year
after this game was played for those of
you who enjoy a good Queens gambit
declined the game this is gonna be quite
a treat so let's see this game Rasmussen
has the white pieces and he opens up
with d4 we have d5 c4 e6 Knight to f3
Knight to f6
so the Queens gambit declined and g3
starting starting the Catalan opening D
captures on c4 and the bishop to g2 now
we enter the closed Catalan Bishop to b4
check Bishop to d2 and now we have this
c5 move here why can y can do a couple
of things he can play a 3-2 force black
to capture on b2 he can either maybe
even capture on c5 where black will
recapture on c5 but this is perfectly
fine for black in the game Bishop
captures and before was played we have a
C capture some b4 and now Knight to e5
opening up this light square bishop
diagonal also attacking the c4 pawn and
it's not not possible to defend the pawn
so here Robson castles we have castles
and Knight captures on c4 Knight to c6
we have III he 5 and this 5 move is
actually a pretty pretty pretty cool
move it gives a white a lot of options
so what can capture D captures on e5 you
can get play Knight captures on e5
Bishop captures on c6 but there is also
the move d5 and this was played in the
game after d5 black doesn't really have
any other option but to push b5 if he
moves the knight who loses d5 pawn so b5
the only move ended the best move we
have D captors on c6 and B cat first
Queen Kaptur sandy one would check King
captures and now B captures and c4 and
now White has a protected pawn and c6 it
looks like a very strong point the
bishop is protecting it and black has to
- very nice pawns and b4 and c4 and here
it's very important what you do here
with white in the game a3 was played and
this wasn't the best move the best idea
to approach this is play something like
Knights - D - and after night - D -
attacking the c4 pawn you will you will
you will force black to push c3 and then
you will exchange one of one of his
strong pawns in the game a3 was played
and now the first Bishop to g4 check
King c1 and now b3 and after this B
three move white provoked this so he can
develop the knight but also after either
of these rooks come to come to the eight
it will be very hard for a white to
develop the rock on a1 so Knight to c3
what gets the develop is Knight rook a
to c8 I will have h3 Bishop to e6 and
rope to d1 now rook F to b8 we have F 4
V 4 and G for preparing g5 to kick away
tonight but here Robson plays Knight to
d5 and I'm very interested if Robson saw
the way this game was gonna play out at
the moment he played this Knight to d5
move it would be very very cool if he
did here he gives up d4 pawn Bishop
captures on e4 and Knight captures on e3
now attacking the rook on d1 rook
captures rook captures and we have c7
and it seems like black has to keep a
rook on the eighth-ranked for example he
has to block it with rook to c7 and then
the King can the White King can come
into the game but instead of this he
decides not to do it and he decides to
sacrifice a piece he decides to play
rook to d4 and now white immediately
plays Bishop to b7 threatening c8
promoting
Queen and there is no way to defend this
but this is all a part of Robson's plan
here eight-six was played
now f5 Bishop to d7 and now pushing the
pawn to c8 promoting to a queen and this
comes with Jack so Bishop captures
Bishop captures and if you look at this
position white just won a piece okay
black is up upon but if you really look
at the position and the engine really
doesn't understand what's going on here
what is still up what is up a piece but
white can't develop the rook he can't
really move the King anywhere and he
can't move the knight if he moves the
knight anywhere then rook to d1 is
checkmate so sorry so black has a rook
on a dark square he has a knight on a
dark square and with white having only a
light square Bishop that is movable
there is really nothing white can do and
blacks plan is simply amazing a black
room how black will now bring his King
into the game and the white can only
wait and see what happens
Robson's plan is to play King f8 to e7
to f6 the g5 to f4 to g3 to F 2 to e1
and after the King comes to e1 he will
checkmate the white king so let's see
how this is done King to f8 we have
Bishop to a6 rook to d6 attacking the
bishop bishop moves
we have a5 Bishop to f3 King to e7 we
have a for this a5 move had to be played
so white couldn't push a5 himself and
maybe develop the rook through a4 so
rook to d4 we have Bishop to e2 King to
f6 h 4 into e5 row to be 1 white doesn't
have anything to do here King to f4
tonight the b5 now attacking the rook
rook 2d work to the 7 not allowing
Knight any squares Knight back to c3
keep the g3 now g5 h captors on g5 h
captors on g5 and King to f2 Bishop to
h5 we have kinked
one and here Rasmussen played f6g
captures on f6 was played G captors on
f6 and now rook to d2 by Robson with the
threat of rook to c2 with checkmate
so rook to a-1 and making room for the
White King can be one but still rook to
c2 checkmate came to be one and now
Knight to f1 and it was in this position
after Knight to f1 where Allen Rasmussen
resigned the game what's the idea here
black wants to play Knight to d2
checkmate and there are two ways to stop
this checkmate one is to play Knight to
e4 and this stops nothing really
black will still play Knight - did you
check and after Knight capture screen
captures and now there is no defense
against wrote to c1 checkmate because
all the action is happening on the dark
squares and the white only has the light
square bishop and after this night - f1
you can also play something like rook to
a3 but it doesn't help still night - did
you check King moves rook to c1 check
now Knight blocks but the knight from d2
is now also attacking the b1 square so
simply rook capture some b1 and this is
checkmate
so after this night - f1 move
Dana Grand Master Alan Rasmussen
resigned to the game but there was a
very interesting moment here after this
King to e1 was played here Rasmussen
pushed f6 an interesting approach to
maybe try and defend this would be
Bishop to f3 with the idea of Bishop to
e4 so the bishop from efore can guarded
the c2 square but this actually doesn't
help white and this is an even greater
greater variation and that unfortunately
didn't happen in the game here again you
play roof to d2 and after Bishop to e4
now guarding the C 2 square now we have
this utterly amazing move Knight to d5
and this this is just insane this almost
puts black in a 2-1 after a couple of
pawn moves are played because if you
capture the night with the bishop you
get rook to c2 and this is checkmate if
you capture the night with the night
then you get of course
rope to D
d1 this is checkmate if you ignore this
and you play something like f6 then
black simply blocks or captures for
example characters captures and black
can now either capture on f6 and then
bring the knight back doesn't really
matter but even better would be for
black to actually block this with like
g6 and now white doesn't have a move he
can't capture with the bishop he can't
capture with Knight only move he can try
is rook to a1 but now comes Knight
captures on c3 be captures on c3 and b2
with check King has to move pawn
captures rook on a1 this is with check
King captures and now with a rook
against the bishop bishop black has a
completely winning endgame so this is
one of the variations that was very nice
but didn't actually happen in the game I
do do hope you enjoyed that variation as
well as the game I would like to thank
Salim Baba Sky Blu music and Jay Jarvis
for a contribution to my channel thank
you what I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I don't know if I will be seeing you
soon as tomorrow flying to Germany for a
week I will be back on the 19th of
January so maybe I will post something
during my stay but I don't think I'll be
able to make any videos which analysis
maybe I will try doing a vlog or
something we'll see if you don't hear
from me you know so you don't get
worried I'm in Germany and I'm coming
back on 19th of January if any of you
are interested what's going on in
Germany but Pearman feel free to follow
me on Instagram I will probably post
some photos and videos of anything that
I find interesting there and maybe even
some chess clubs or something so yeah
that's all for this video thank you for
watching and I will see you probably
after I get back from Germany thank you
all